en russie chaque nouvelle journée
continue de battre le record de la paix
quasiment 25 mille 500 nouveaux cas ces
dernières 24 heures dont 6075 plus du
quart pour la seule ville de moscou
principal foyer de cette pandémie
mais pour autant pas de confinement
seules mesures restrictives au delà du
port du masque et des gants
la fermeture des bars et restaurants à
23 heures il faut dire que le maire de
moscou mise sur deux choses
l'immunité collective dont il estime que
la moitié des moscovites est dorénavant
notée et la vaccination de la population
qui est maintenant imminente
nous sommes prêts pour la vaccination de
masse
nous avons mis en place près de 300
points de vaccination équipé de tout le
matériel nécessaire de réfrigérateurs et
de personnel un système d'information
électronique a été créé pour
l'inscription gratuite des citoyens à la
vaccination est l'objectif est le même
pour le reste du pays
mais à l'échelle du territoire russe le
défi logistique et organisationnelle est
autrement plus important
je ne peux pas vous indiquer de date
précise mais le processus de vaccination
doit être lancé avant la fin de l'année
cependant quand on dit de masse d'abord
il faut dire qu'il s'agit d'une
vaccination volontaire cela va donc se
faire par étapes
l'objectif étant tout de même de faire
en sorte que ces étapes dures le moins
de temps possible et qu'on puisse
fournir le vaccin à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent le plus vite possible
on le voit bien un scénario à la
française avec confinement strict n'est
pas d'actualité en russie d'autant que
les autorités tablent maintenant sur la
vaccination de masse pour faire reculer
la bande et